there are articles all around the world
with pronouns like he/she/it they a lot
of people just are not quite sure what I
am and honestly a little mystery is kind
of fun
I'm Rayne dev and I am a model activist
and general enjoyer of life so I model
as both a male and a female or in both
menswear and womenswear I worked as a
male bartender I've worked as a
firefighter for a while
under a male persona I've done
landscaping as male oh I did power
washing for a while in Long Island I
feel like every day that I do more
modeling every day that I say I'm not
going to stop doing what I'm doing it's
another day in which I'm representing a
community that isn't stopping what
they're doing either
my mission is not to look fancy my
mission is to show people that they
belong that they are beautiful that they
are handsome that they are attractive
and that they deserve to be elevated it
is hard to protect yourself from being
exploited and turned into a gimmick by
designers who are trying something new
or trying to get a bang for their buck
but at the same time in a weird way I
really want to be exploited I want
somebody to say yeah let's try a gimmick
because I want them to see how wildly
successful that gimmick is I want them
to start putting people that look like
me or that people that are different on
the runway regularly I'm really hoping
that people see that I'm not a model I'm
a movement I'm a human and like that's
it